for a couple of weeks and yet your
circumstance
would seem to suggest that that is not
true that that is not the full extent
of of the downside of that that there is
more cost
and sometimes that cost is born not just
in a in an inconvenience
but in someone being left vulnerable
yeah absolutely in my case it would have
compounded the
problem um of course i was depressed who
wouldn't be
of course i had nightmares who wouldn't
after going through that but to take
away
my basic human right of self-defense on
top of all of that
would just be devastating for someone
like me
sometimes people will argue um
the process is great in everything um
but um
with respect to the bad folks we can't
give them due process
isn't that the problem with due process
itself
i mean if we're going to respect due
process aren't we agreeing
upfront that due process needs to be up
front it's not really due process
if it's only after the fact is that
right that is right
and i understand it can be very scary i
mean i
i get it i get it i'm a victim of a
violent crime
um but like i said if you truly believe
that someone is a danger
they should be confined to a mental
facility
but they should have due process and and
that's why i
support um the baker act and similar
laws that already exist
all across the nation every state has a
similar lot of that
because it includes due process
your your legal fees are paid covered
they're not under red flag laws
you know i don't have ten thousand
dollars to cover
legal fees it can be very very expensive
and with the baker acts and similar laws
mental health experts are involved
that's not always the case with red flag
laws
and i think that's very important that
mental health experts be involved in
that due process
mr copel um
does lack of notice and due process
sometimes might go along with gun
confiscation orders
doesn't this have some potential to
increase the risk of harm
both to law enforcement officers
executing the orders and to those
who are subject to those orders
sure you imagine a situation where
officers there's a ex party order that's
been issued
and you know made weak evidence and the
guy's really not dangerous
but the uh
confiscation order is served by the
police showing up at somebody's house at
five o'clock in the morning
you know normally and a homeowner might
think it was a burglary
and and uh because he has no no idea
that anybody's coming to take his guns
and and there's also a broader problem
in the in how it erodes
trust between law enforcement and and
the public and this was
talked about in one of the uh
connecticut studies that's uh quoted in
the in my written testimony
when you have somebody whose guns are
taken away
and confiscated the police show up i've
you know never heard of
anything going on against me but now
there's a cop
coming to take my guns as the
some connecticut state police officers
have reported
these are often the guys who think of
themselves as the most pro-cop
you know they're the ones who were on
this back the blue on the side of law
enforcement understand it's a tough job
and then all of a sudden the guys they
thought they were that were their
friends
are there to take away their their
property when
it's a complete surprise to the person
and then maybe a few weeks later
the person hires lawyer goes into court
they get their guns back
but in the meantime it's been a very
humiliating process for the
wrongly accused individual and law
enforcement who've
often represented in amicus brief in
courts and
elsewhere are so dependent
on the cooperation and goodwill of the
public you know that that's the american
model we're not
uh policing from above like in some
other less free countries
so when these are done wrongfully uh
they really break that relationship and
bond between the public and law
enforcement that that is necessary
to successful law enforcement and public
safety
mr coach there are a number of us myself
included
who have formed sort of a bipartisan
coalition raising concerns
in a related area of civil asset
forfeiture
where in areas outside of
firearms we've raised concerns with law
enforcement being able to take people's
property
first and then ask questions later to
take first
and then provide some sort of process
later
due process of course
has a higher expectation than that does
it not and do you see that
tell me what you think about the
parallel uh between this and that in
other words
if one is concerned about the potential
for abuse and the actuality of abuse in
the civil asset forfeiture arena
how could one not see something similar
uh
when it extends to the second amendment
it's the same kind of situational kind
of situation and both are
have good intentions of trying to deal
with a serious problem the
pure uh gun crime and uh then civil
asset forfeiture
it had always existed in kind of a minor
way but it really got ramped up in a
huge way
in the 70s and 80s uh because of the
drug war and
of course drug abuse can be very harmful
uh not only to an individual but to
society more broadly and so the idea was
well we need these tools to fight the
drug lords and all this
and what happened was there were a lot
of people whose property got taken
who weren't colombian drug lords or
anything like that
and it was widely abused and
sadly the courts uh in their view of
what
the minimum cost what the constitution
requires
as a minimum for due process generally
said that's fine
so i would urge this especially this
committee of all
committees in the united states which is
charged with defending the constitution
that
one of the reasons courts often defer to
legislative judgments
is they presume just like chief justice
marshall said in mcculloch versus
maryland
that the legislature itself already
seriously thought
about constitutional rights and values
so i think legislators can and should
go above whatever minimal level uh the
judiciary will enforce in terms of the
protection of people's procedural rights
so insofar as we're talking about
um a due process right it is
freestanding
here which i i think we've agreed that
there is
certainly uh a right doesn't lose
protection
by becoming a hybrid right in other
words if you already have
a freestanding independent due process
right protected by the fifth amendment
or the 14th amendments due process
clause
you certainly don't see that any
justification for diluting that right
merely because you've added the second
amendment into the equation by virtue of
its
involvement in the firearms arena
yes at least as a uh policy matter you
would think due process would be all the
stronger there and of course the the
analogy as i'm sure you know in the
first
supreme court's uh free exercise of
religion jurisprudence
sometimes that free exercise of religion
gets
stronger protection when it's a hybrid
in conjunction with the exercise of some
other right
right right i've never quite understood
uh
the uh the hybrid rights doctrine in the
first amendment context beyond what you
just described which is that
it certainly doesn't get weaker when you
compound one right with another and i
would maintain that
that is no less true here consistent
with the directive i was given
from the chairman when he left to go
vote
uh i hereby recess
this hearing of the subcommittee subject
to the call of the chair who will be
back momentarily thank you
we are back uh we're going to be joined
shortly by senator graham and senator
cruz at least
and perhaps others
and i will yield to senator graham when
he
arrives but i have a few questions um
in the meantime first let me ask the
panel
uh because i wasn't here whether
everyone got a chance to respond to
senator lee's questions or
if there's anything else you would like
to say
while we're waiting for others to come
back
all right mr white if if
we're available um i would just i think
it's important to
make the case that in these situations
i'm not a we're talking a lot about
civil asset forfeiture i'm not an expert
in
in that law at all so i can't claim to
that but i do know that this
the due process protections in
irpo laws are very similar to other
civil orders especially
domestic violence orders but also in
cases some cases of
civil commitment as well as in child
endangerment situations where there's an
urgency to act
so i don't know that the analogy is
exactly perfect for
civil asset forfeiture because i think
what we're talking to
about here is danger to persons
so i think the analogy is a little
different and when you think about due
process protections that have been
upheld
you can see that in numerous uh numerous
other fields
that the type of arrangement that's
built here is
um available in other fields and so i
think we tried to build this with that
in mind
and i just you know and one of the
things you think about indiana's
original law
you know in that law firearm removal has
been upheld
even without uh hearing it a attempt
temporary hearing
to begin with and when we built sort of
what we see
indiana and connecticut were the first
and as we built the laws moving forward
we wanted to add that hearing at the
beginning
so that no firearm was ever removed
without a judge
looking at least at ex parte looking at
the evidence
so i think there's more protection here
than people
than we would and some folks have looked
at through this and i think it's in line
with what we've seen
in long-standing domestic violence
protection orders
as i as i mentioned i will yield to
senator graham whenever he's ready to go
thank you mr chairman uh yeah thank you
very much very good here
appreciate it um mr koppel is that right
are you still with us
uh yeah i hope so okay
well i enjoyed our last engagement where
we're trying to find a way
um on the front end and the back end to
give adequate due process
but also address the problem and
uh i think the indiana situation is a
good one to miss
goes-r is that right your story made me
think
about you know we want to make sure
we're thinking this thing through and
uh not go too far with it but i've just
come to believe mr chairman like
like you have that states who've adopted
these laws
and probably are on the right track
the cruise situation in parkland 30
visits by the police
every warning sign known to mankind
and they were powerless
and governor scott working with the
state house passed a
florida version of the red flag laws
indiana was one of the first ones to do
this
in the situation where the young man had
the shotgun
taken because of his mental health
status
but there was no implementation
um is something that i'm sure we don't
want to have happen
again so mr koppel
when it comes time to write
a grant program let's say incentivizing
states
to go down this road on the due process
front you're advocating that
there be a civil cause of action in case
somebody is accused
wrongfully or maliciously that they can
actually have recourse against their
accuser is that right
yes not a not a mistaken accusation
because everybody makes mistakes in
including me as we
discussed earlier in this hearing uh but
a a knowing
and malicious accusation so i talked
with the chairman about that
that makes sense to me that that if
somebody is trying to
ruin your life and accuse you of
something you're you're not then they'll
have a redress
so i like that the ex parte nature of
the hearing
the initial determination by the judge
to act what kind of standard would you
suggest we create there i'd
say start with the federal rules of
civil procedure which generally
disfavor ex parte uh decisions
but allow a judge to issue orders ex
parte on a
uh on a guided set of facts and and
findings about necessity and pretty
particularly
why is the other person not here in
court why didn't this person have notice
and sometimes the per person seeking a
temporary restraining order
can give a good answer to that and some
on which i am not an expert no i got you
but yeah you got to pick a standard that
seems to be a good one to me
uh the time period between the initial
determination and a full-blown hearing
what would you recommend
i'd suggest we talk to prosecutors and
uh including some of the witnesses here
who who have experience with this
and and say what what is a realistic uh
time period on the one hand we want to
be expeditious
on on the other hand maybe there's some
time needed to gather evidence
all right based on your research of the
existing state laws which one
do you think has done the best job of
threading this needle
and why and which ones do you have the
most concern about and why
vermont may be best overall although
connecticut has some good features in it
too and especially the requirement that
law enforcement investigate the
situation on their own
uh before filing a request for a
petition
colorado with its providing for uh
defenders
uh defense lawyers in this case i think
is
a very strong model and and uh
not only helps the individual but i i
think also may function as a deterrent
to potential abuses on
on the other side i'd say massachusetts
has
some of the weakest standards for due
process in new jersey
actually once you've got the the person
actually gets an in-person hearing
and there's a confiscation order it has
the effect of being permanent
uh preventing the person from ever
owning a gun again unless they come back
into court and
prove that they're not a danger uh so i
think the model
mr horowitz's organization has talked
about where the order automatically
terminates
after a certain period of time it can be
renewed upon
new further proof about the individual
at that new time is the better way to go
okay we'll just sum it up here i want to
go over basically you believe
the most constitutionally sound way to
do this would be not a federal law
but some grant program that would
emphasize
adequate and robust due process is that
fair to say
yes and i think that the states and
localities have the resources to do this
in a way that the
the federal marshals and uh others just
don't have the manpower for
among other reasons thank you thank you
thanks senator graham um senator cruz
did you have a other question
um mr ben cuomo
you're a gun owner yourself i'm going to
assume you're a law-abiding one
has colorado's law been tied to mass
confiscation of firearms from gun owners
like yourself
first of all i am definitely a
responsible gun owner so thank you
um and from what we know from today
obviously i'm not a scholar or a lawyer
or an attorney um
we have not seen mass confiscations one
area that we could do an improvement
i was glad to hear that we hit the high
marks on a good
that we're a good role model not only do
we have defense lawyers i would love to
see federal funding so that we can
ensure that there's psas
public safety announcements and
education for the additional responsible
gun owners of colorado
are you familiar with instances where
it's been used
to retaliate against people
or
indicatively by family members or
business associates against each other
well i am not
and it's been about a year since
colorado's law has been in effect
correct
that is correct um
notwithstanding that some counties have
declared themselves to be second
amendment
sanctuaries and some sheriffs
have announced plans to block the law
from being used
i understand um quite a few have
reversed their opposition
after seeing how the law is actually put
into effect is that correct
that is correct and that that those
citations are listed in my written
testimony i wouldn't be able to speak to
them today
but they are they are listed
well i i thank you for coming here and
talking about how
it has saved veterans lives because they
are
at risk of suicide and this law
obviously has
worked effectively to protect them um
mr horowitz um
mr capo referred to your statute as one
that seems to have been framed to meet
the due process standard
and that it is based on the best
examples of laws
throughout the country
and he alluded to the resources
necessary to implement such a law
would a law
from congress that provided those
resources and training
encourage states to adopt the best kind
of standards as you have advocated
i think the federal government could do
a lot to encourage the the proper
standards for these laws
um i do think we've seen in kim white is
the best example of what her unit does
but where there is
robust funding you'll see
all sorts of services for for getting
these done but also
for the respondents and the petitioners
but what you don't see is that for
instance
outside of king county where ms wyatt
works the implementation
is really different and so what we're
seeking is
those federal resources to make sure
that the same processes that we've seen
work in washington so what
king county can do in every county that
needs this and i will say
that suicide and you know from my
testimony you know that i care a lot
about this
some of the highest suicide rates are in
rural counties
who are least able to afford the types
of
training the types of uh investments
that other counties have done so
i think as a suicide prevention tool i
think the federal government has a big
role to play
in providing that technical assistance
that training
and the resources to really develop a
process so things don't fall through the
cracks
but there's also the types of services
that would make this really work
we've been talking a little bit about
the
protective orders domestic violence
protective orders
they impose restraints on constitutional
rights do they not
they certainly do well beyond what an
extreme risk protection order does so
uh domestic violence uh restraining
orders can often
keep you from your bank account from
your kids from your home
and in some states uh even on a
temporary basis your firearms so
um what we're talking about here is just
one slice of that but based on the same
standard
it's a very surgical type of tool here
and that's the point of this and
i was glad to see mr coppol talking
about ways that we can agree on this
because i do think we can do that
i think we can get there i think we can
make this tool safe
to use around the country to i think we
can meet you come to the middle and find
agreement
and make sure that we're saving lives
i was encouraged as well quite honestly
by his statement to that effect and
i i thank him for his
his testimony today but also his candor
in
describing what he knows and what he
doesn't know because not all
not all of us are experts on all the
facets of
these laws but just from a
constitutional standpoint
the restraints on liberty involved in
domestic violence
orders in fact they are called
restraining orders because they restrict
liberty
the civil commitment statute which takes
away
at least somebody's liberty
uh there are all kinds of ways in which
those fundamental liberties
are impinged
to keep society safe and they
established procedures to do it
so that those orders are fact based
and a burden of showing those facts is
put on the person who would seek to take
away that liberty or any other rights
and that basic concept is what we have
here and the idea that an order expires
if it is unchallenged or unverified
within a
period of time and a firearm is then
returned
certainly is a source of protection is
it not
it is and as mr coppell said we're we
really believe that the
at the end of the order the firearm
should be returned
it should not be a complicated process
there are
options to renew but at the same burden
as the original
it doesn't the burden should should not
shift from the petitioner in those
circumstances
if there's a renewal petition made it
should again be on the petitioner to
plead the
the elements of the statute and
in a certain sense we can actually not
only
encourage states to adopt
these kinds of statues but also elevate
the
levels the quality of those statutes if
we
offer incentives for them to do it in
the form of grants and other
support right i mean as as senator cruz
said the states are all over
are you know the laboratories of
democracy and there's different
processes in different states and i
think you're starting to see
some you know coalescing around some of
the best practices there
um and hopefully the federal funding can
really
improve that and um and make that
continue to make that process that
coalescing develop
so that the law we learn we learn from
what the best practices are we learn
from people like
kim wyatt what what really works and
that we end up developing a program that
saves lives across the country
uh i think uh ms wyatt i asked you
earlier
about the importance of
resources to your unit
and you have a very
well-staffed unit with experts and
prosecutors
and so forth which has costs
could you talk a little bit about the
value that federal resources would have
to help you implement the best practices
of that unit
sure and just to give a little context
you know we
are evolving as our unit has grown since
january 2018. last year in 2020
we had at least 73 law enforcement
petitions herbos
and six were from family so we
realized on a daily basis the need to
educate the public
and educate the community from faith
leaders to school
officials therapists medical providers
law enforcement throughout the whole
state and federal authorities
or federal law enforcement as well so
there's a need
overall to educate the public because if
you have a law
and nobody knows about it then it's not
doing any of us any good so that would
be the number one thing is to get a
public education
out and then the second thing i think is
really critically important
is to have funding for individuals who
are
implementing herbal laws in their state
or
to be able to create a model policy for
law enforcement so
law enforcement understands how are we
supposed to serve these orders which are
very similar to other civil protection
orders
but once we created a model policy and
assisted law enforcement in our county
we had much more buy-in from our local
law enforcement
because it was this tangible attainable
task so i would suggest doing doing some
of those things but education is the
number one thing and then the second is
to bring all the system players together
so that folks from the clerk's office
where the orders will be filed
to victim advocates who may be reaching
out to families
to also guide their loved one who's in
crisis to get some resources
i think that's critically important and
one area where we lack in our state
is the need to have some money for
individuals that are subject to the
herbal
who need a behavioral health evaluation
funding is needed to be able to guide
those individuals to be able to get that
evaluation
and to be able to give them some help
once they've been
subject to one of these orders i think
that's critically important
thank you very much i'm going to yield
to senator cruz i have a few
final questions but in case he has to
leave i'll yield
thank you mr chairman um i've got a
couple of questions let me start with mr
koppel
um
mr couple since since you testified two
years ago
additional states have enacted red flag
laws and and multiple states have
amended their laws
and it seems that they've all amended
them in the direction of providing less
protection of due process
and less protection of second amendment
rights for example california amended
its law to allow
a disgruntled co-worker to initiate the
process
for confiscating a fellow co-workers
firearm
do you agree that the trend is for these
laws to get broader and broader
and less and less protective of
fundamental rights and
and if so why do you think this is
happening
oh because yeah maybe it's the slippery
slope that always happens on on all
kinds
of laws is people get it enacted
in one way and saying look how narrow it
is and then when it's
there then they start thinking of ways
how to to broaden it further and further
and again i think connecticut has the
right approach on
saying anybody who's got a concern about
someone else
can come to a law enforcement office or
a peace officer or a state's attorney
and and bring that forward problem
forward
but they can't just because you had a
fight with a guy at work
you can't file a petition yourself
against that individual
and law enforcement is supposed to do
its own independent investigation
and that seems the best way to uh start
off the process
at the beginning with the the higher
quality
of uh information to give to the judge
thank you for that and i think that's a
very good point
as we discussed earlier i'm i'm a strong
believer in federalism
and right now 19 states and the district
of columbia have red flag laws
and there's not much quality evidence
about their effectiveness
or lack thereof although there's some
good evidence demonstrating that they
have a very high error rate
could you give a bit more color on what
the evidence and the data
shows about these laws so
for a lot of folks the the rand
corporation's uh continuing project on
assessing
uh doing a meta study of all the social
science on on the the gun issue
uh has found some things particular gun
controls
to be effective and in their evaluation
of this
their view was none of the the
studies that exist so far meet our
standards for
for data quality and persuasiveness um
so they're on the one and one there's
nothing there from
the brand's point of view but even
beyond that
uh i don't know of any study that's ever
said there's a statistically noticeable
change in crime or or mass shootings
of along with other crimes but i also
say that you don't have to
a law doesn't have to be proven to have
a statistically significant effect
to be beneficial if you reduce
homicide by half of a percent uh
in a state that may be statisticians
may not be able to see that and know
that there's a cause and effect
but but that's still a beneficial uh
thing to do the the suicide data uh
is is mixed uh one study said that it
went down
farm suicide declined in uh indiana
and wasn't replaced by other methods uh
another the study found in connecticut
actually fire suicide to decline but
other deaths by other methods went up um
on that it's really important to know
that there are
lots of nearly as lethal substitutes
for firearms uh such as as hanging
uh that have very high mortality rates
as well
the the the theory that for every 10 or
20
of these confiscation orders that get us
get gets issued
one suicide was prevented is really just
a hypothetical extrapolation
and it makes the mistake of saying that
every form of self-harm
was a suicide attempt you know a teenage
girl who who cuts her arm
isn't trying to commit suicide she's
certainly indicating she's got a serious
problem
but the that that 10 or 20 to one figure
is uh it is not supportable because it
assumes that every form
of self-harm uh is
an intentional suicide which is
definitely not true
thank you uh ms goser
in your opening testimony you
you testified that that red flag laws
can have a chilling effect
that can cause victims to fear losing
their rights
if they seek help by talking with
friends or family or psychologists
can you elaborate on that concern please
sure i think that um when people
fear that you know someone may be very
very very
depressed and still be concerned
for their own safety which i'm sure to
some people that doesn't make sense but
um when people are
concerned that they're going to lose
their rights they bottle up
like they're not they're not going to
want to share their feelings and i just
think
it's best that these people be able to
get you know
mental health help and
if if they feel intimidated if they feel
like they might lose their rights it
could actually have the opposite
effect from what you want
and advocates for red flag laws
often focus on the benefit of
removing a firearm from a potentially
dangerous person and there's no doubt
that with someone with serious mental
illness or
or an intent to do real harm that that
can be a
a very real benefit but
they also diminish
the harm of removing a firearm from
someone who might be a victim of
violence for whom that firearm
might be the difference between
surviving a violent attack
and and not surviving a violent attack
do you agree with that
um yeah i i've
got to tell you this i think and i've
gotten to know a lot of
victims um i've actually brought my
friend amanda collins johnson with me
she's sitting
just behind me here she um
she was brutally raped on her college
campus it was
of course a gun-free zone and it was in
the student parking garage
she had her permit to carry but because
she was obeying that gun control law she
left her gun
at home she wasn't allowed to have it on
campus
and that's where a serial rapist found
her
on her way to her car in the student
parking garage
and he brutally raped her right there in
the
in the garage and
i've gotten to know a lot of other
victims and they all
want the ability to protect themselves
but we also
fear that you know some of our attackers
are going to be released you know people
seem to think that if you do a horrible
violent crime that you're just going to
be in prison forever that's not true
murderers really horrible people that do
very violent things they're let out of
prison every
day in this country unfortunately
and that's very scary for us
and victims want to be able to protect
themselves but
here's a scenario perhaps you've not
thought of which absolutely terrifies me
when my stalker my husband's murderer is
released one day
what would prevent him from taking out a
red flag
on me to purposefully disarm me
so that he can harm me that's terrifying
that's just something to think about
well thank you miss collins johnson for
having
the courage to be here and allowing your
story to be told
and and ms goser thank you for speaking
on her behalf and on behalf of so many
victims of violence
thank you uh thank you thank you senator
cruz you know i'm struck
as we come to the end of this hearing by
the points of agreement
perhaps unintentional ms gosur
your point about people who have mental
illness
perhaps
being reluctant to talk to friends or
professionals
is exactly the point that senator durbin
made
i don't know whether you recall but he
said
people should not be
separated from firearms simply because
they have a mental illness
it's dangerous it's risk
it's potential harm to others
that murderer would have no basis
none for going to a judge
and saying nikki gosur
is dangerous a risk of harm to anyone
on the contrary and likewise senator
cruz and i
are both federalists i was a state
attorney general for way longer than
i've been a united states senator
i believe in states rights
to enforce their own laws and need to
make their own laws
and that is the whole purpose of our
proposed
red flag statue
not only to encourage states to make
their own laws but to make them
better so when they do pass their laws
they look more like
thanks to mr koppel for his compliment
to connecticut
more like connecticut than say one of
the other states that
he found less protective
of constitutional rights if they're
going to be laboratories of democracy
better to elevate the results
of those laboratories than
let them kind of muddle along
and fail to protect the rights of
american citizens
so i think there's a lot here
where we have common ground as long as
we don't
become distracted and i understand your
point
about gun-free zones about
permitting
[Music]
the most heinous kind of
law breakers perhaps to go free and
threaten others
we ought to prevent that but
we're talking here about a more narrowly
crafted law with a more narrow purpose
that can be surrounded by all kinds of
protections
relating to what has to be proved in the
way of factual evidence the standard
that has to be met
not just probable cause the
protections for individuals
you know you could say that someone
who's unable to afford an attorney
has to be provided with one i'm just
thinking out loud here
but um my hope is
that we can go forward and
sort of focus on the common ground
because if we do want states to be the
laboratories of democracy better to make
them
good laboratories and protective of
constitutional rights then allow them to
just
go forward without encouragement to
adopt
higher standards you know
um i think mr koppel has been very frank
on the issue of whether there are
authoritative studies
a lot of the evidence here is
anecdotally it relies on
common sense but if somebody says i'm
going to
shoot people
in parkland i'm going to kill students
and as senator graham has said the
shooter
practically took out an ad in the
newspaper and said i'm dangerous
that it makes sense to give the police
and i take his point about the police
which is in the connecticut statute the
authority to make their case
may be screened by a prosecutor as
happens in
the state of washington we've heard ms
wyatt describe that procedure with all
kinds of
protections and bells and whistles
rather than
allowing that shooter to just go ahead
so i think um
i am determined to try to seize that
common ground
and um make the case that we can work
together
on these kinds of uh statues i'm willing
to hear
from um any of the witnesses who want to
make any sort of final
remarks or senator cruz if if he has
anything
mr horowitz i just want to thank
everybody from the committee for mr
chairman for the ranking member for
giving this a fair
undertaking and i i really believe that
we can reach
an agreement here i think it's important
to save lives i think we can protect due
process we can protect constitutional
lights and save lives and for everybody
on this panel
i think we want to come together and
that's what we want to do is save lives
and i hope
the members of this committee can hear
what we've taken today
craft something that really works and um
and save lives so thank you for this
time i'm
deeply appreciative of being here today
and for this very serious consideration
thank you
thank you to all the uh witnesses thanks
to senator cruz
uh and all the colleagues who appeared
here the record will remain open for one
week
and anyone with questions can submit
you